next awards will be given for costume
design and to present them we have two
people a beautiful star who has often
been described as an elegantly gaunt
lady miss Dina Mero and a gifted
favorite who's often described as a
spiffy dresser
mr. Eddie Albert
well should we get to it smithy well
first cutting it sniffing first I'd like
to thank Bob for that nice introduction
did you mean that though well of course
you're always so well-groomed Eddie
what's your secret well for example to
make my hair lie down I use that greasy
stuff the kids use you know
oh yes peanut butter and now for the
best achievement and costume design of a
black-and-white picture the nominees are
Dorothy Jenkins for the children's hour
the model is sue Barton Howard shoot for
Claudell English
the model is Sharon hugenay
poor judgment at Nuremburg
and the model is Roxanne Arlen
before la dolce vita
and the model is an helm
and Yoshida Baraka for Yojimbo
the model is Lange noon and will you
announce the winner you know the winner
is Piero Garrity for La Dolce Vita
it is personal but implicit Matt Thank
You Greta
and now for the color costume design
nominees just a minute it may it occurs
to me that some viewers may have just
tuned in and wondered why they're not
seeing Ben Casey
oh well then explain to him that he's
off duty tonight
that's right dr. Casey is not working
he's confined to his bed with a severe
frown this is actually the 34th annual
Academy Awards and the next item of
business is costume design of a color
picture the nominees are Bill Thomas for
babes in toyland
that the model is Patricia McNulty
Jean we for backstreet
the model is Nancy Walters
Eirene sheriff for Flower Drum Song
the model is Karla most
model is Natalie trendy
and Irene sheriff for West Side Story
the model is Brooke Bundy and the winner
miss Merrow the winner is Irene sheriff
for Westside stone
cooking for Irene Charo miss Angeli
on behalf of Irene shelters very busy in
Rome I thank you
the next award will be for Supporting
Actor